messieurs dames comment allez-vous
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas de casse vous
savez ce que ça veut dire vidéo
anecdotes et oui mais attention en place
tombe pieds nus aussi s'est jamais
arrivé chez en roue libre là pour cette
rentrée écoutez je pensais pas refaire
de sitôt une vidéo anecdotes mais cet
été pour la première fois de ma vie j'ai
tenté une semaine d'une foule le road
trip prendre sa voiture ne pas savoir où
tu dors le soir même improvisé faire les
choses sur le tard un vrai challenge
pour moi qui suis vraiment le plus gros
des bébé cadum c'est une expérience que
j'avais jamais fait de ma vie maintenant
je sais pourquoi je l'avais jamais fait
pourquoi je vais vous parler du road
trip parce que les deux premiers jours
de ce road trip se sont pas bien passées
d'accord alors tant mieux pour vous
parce que du coup cette vidéo existent
mais moi sur le moment les gars j'étais
vraiment vraiment pas bien succession de
mauvaises décisions camping fantômes qui
fait peur soirée avec les habitants du
village de resident evil 8 alors qu'ils
sont nos quatre aventuriers déterminé
dans la première voiture un renault
scénic aménagé pour l'occasion c'est à
dire que les sièges arrière sont
baissées tu peux t'amuser dans le coffee
dormir c'est bon que nous avons lucioles
vous la connaissez bien elle est robuste
et capable de mettre mal à l'aise toute
une classe d'élèves en une seule phrase
dans cette voiture à ses côtés se trouve
aussi jojo il s'agit de la meilleure
amie de lorette de très loin la plus
route du groupe cette fille pourrait
dormir deux semaines dans un arbre et ça
lui poserait aucun problème laissez moi
maintenant vous parler de la seconde
voiture le meilleur pour la fin une
wayne weaver évoque pas du tout aménagé
pour l'occasion et dont l'espace ne
permet en aucun cas de s'allonger dedans
c'est un détail important nous avons
théo c'est grâce à lui que vous aurez
des images d'archivés tout au long cette
vidéo anecdote il est volontaire
aventuriers conciliant mature mais
appeler le rencontrer le merde et quand
tu l'accusent d'avoir gonflé comme un
ouf toute la nuit et d'avoir empêché
tout le monde de dormir et répond
avec
à ses côtés dans cette voiture florent
hochart mon frère celui qu'a fait ce
tee-shirt il est habitué à l'aventuré il
a gravi des montagnes et après il
manquait d'oxygène il sentait mali ils
redescendent et alors que le groupe
quand tu es monté mais ça je jouerai pas
nul mais surtout il a fait la meilleure
des formations puisqu'il est parti à 8
mois en road trip à travers toute
l'amérique du sud argentine colombie
brésil pérou bolivie
bref il est rodé c'est le capitaine de
l'as range-rover et dans cette voiture
se trouve aussi moi je conduis et je me
plais beaucoup
regardons reprend une autoroute qui va
vers toulouse maintenant vous connaissez
toutes les personnes qui ont participé à
ce road trip il est temps de vous
raconter les deux premiers jours le
point de rendez vous c'est tout nous
faut savoir qu'à ce moment-là tôt et moi
on sort d'une semaine de vacances à
biarritz donc tout l'équipement qu'on a
pour faire un road trip c'est du linge
sale pour l'heure d'accord on décide
donc d'aller s'équiper à tes questions
mon magasin préféré après la fnac on
rentre dans le décathlon et là on a ce
truc de la peur de manquer vous voyez
très vous voyez ça la peur des dans une
situation on a oublié d'acheter un truc
à décathlon dont avaient besoin les
revendeurs qui nous repèrent lillois
trois gars montrer à peu près tous les
articles de chaque rayon en disant à
vous de voir l faudrait des preuves dans
celui là d'un j'ai vu ce vendeur
comprendre qu'il allait faire un très
beau chiffre ce jour là et nous dit bell
égard il vous faut un réchaud une
casserole découvert une tente des
couvertures de survie des petits
ouvriers gonflables des chaussons
aquatique un petit parce que de
snorkeling au cas où vous voulez voir
les petits poissons millions dans le lac
ou dans la mer je regarde mon frère
était oh je leur dis les gars wahou mais
quand même pas en train de se faire
arnaquer par un vendeur de décathlon
j'achète mais ce qui nous dit tout y
avait des trucs dans le caddie j'avais
même pas comment les utiliser on en
vient à l'achat inévitable l'achat d'une
tante ces fameuses tentes là qui se
déplie très vite et qui se replient
beaucoup moins vite et avec théo on nous
la fait pas on regarde le vendeur lui
dis ce que tu peux la déplier la repliés
devant nous pendant contes film comme ça
si on est en galère au milieu de la
forêt on regardera cette vidéo et on
suivra t geste il ya 300 vidéos de ça
sur youtube d'accord cette idée n'est
pas original on arrive donc en caisse
avec un caddie avec 80 articles dedans
autres on paye on met tous dans le
coffre de la red river et on est
maintenant prêt à débuter notre semaine
de road trip direction banyuls-sur-mer
on arrive là bas aux alentours de 22h30
après de longues heures de route on a
maintenant un nouvel objectif trouver un
endroit où dormir mais pas d'inquiétude
jojo connaît la localisation d'un spot
magnifique et dont le terrain est idéal
pour camper merveilleux les trucs comme
ça ça sent les spots niche que très peu
de gens connaissent et où tu te régales
on prend donc la route en direction du
fameux spot qui est à 15 minutes de nous
et au bout de trois minutes je reçois un
message de lorraine qui est dans la
renault scénic qui suit la red bull le
message c'est juste lucas ya deux
scooters qui nous suivent
je regarde mon rétroviseur est
effectivement je vois deux scooters qui
nous prennent en filature et même je
reconnais les scooters la marque des
scooters cd mbk booster qui sont
débridés vu que les mecs sont en train
de rouler à 80 km heure ils nous suivent
je le sais parce que j'en voulais un
quand j'avais 14 ans et ma mère elle m'a
juste dit non hélas ce moment précis les
yeux dans le rétro je me dis juste
[ __ ] je veux faire voler la caisse
jour 1 qu'elle kiffe ce road trip le
premier des deux scooters arrive à mon
niveau je tourne la tête en attendant a
tombé sur ça
je me suis bien dessus à ce moment là
mdi ait wifi et on peut faire la photo
la photo il le dit à 80 km/heure moi
j'entends ça
moi je me dis mais attend on est où là
on est à 80 km/heure sur des routes qui
font ça dans des montagnes il fait nuit
noire paie toi tu crois que je vais
m'arrêter pour prendre une photo avec
toi mais bien sûr mon frérot m'étais
warning let's go il est passé de
ravisseurs à meilleur ami de lucas très
vite ce gars je prends sa photo en
repartant il manque de se faire faucher
par une voiture j'ai eu peur le fait
divers bref les photos ont été prises il
repart non redémarre la voiture on vous
reprend la route et on arrive au spot de
jojo et le spot de jojo c'est pas c'est
pas vraiment ce qui était prévu
déjà le vent est tellement fort que
quand tu parles autour personne entend
juste le vent il prend ta phrase est il
l'emmène dans une maison du village au
hasard mais au delà du vent des amis le
sol c'est pas de l'herbe cédé à vis des
graviers qui nous regardent et qui nous
disent vous avez oublié d'acheter de
matelas gonflable de coping du catelet
les graviers ont raison on n'a pas
anticipé un trucs basiques clairement le
spot de jojo c'est mort il s'agit d'un
chemin de gravier littéralement
maintenant on passe au plan b le plan b
il est simple on va dans des campings à
banyuls-sur-mer c'est simple il ya deux
grands pis on se rend donc au premier
camping le portail est fermé le gardien
vient à notre rencontre et nous dit
vous connaissez ce geste ces jo on est
complet jusqu'à mi septembre
e c'était une bonne rencontre malgré
tout mais plutôt quand on était sur les
routes là pour aller au spot de jojo on
est passé devant un truc où il y avait
marqué camping un truc un peu en mode
fête foraine abandonné donc non si bas
venez on retourne aux panneaux camping
qu'on avait vu là-bas et peut-être c'est
juste un camping beaucoup moins connue
et que donc y aura de la place on arrive
donc devant ce deuxième camping sauf que
le panneau il dit pas juste camping est
dit aussi complet on ait explosé il est
1h30 du matin parce que là bas dès que
tu fais le moindre trajet c'est hyper
longue ce que c'est des routes qui sont
des montagnes donc ça fait juste que des
virages tu perds un temps de dengue et
on décide de lancer une petite réunion
de crise tous les cinq pour un peu faire
le tour de nos options et là je croise
le regard de lorraine qui me fixe comme
ça le raid me di luca
c'est chaud pour
en une minute chrono lorraine et jojo
viennent d'installer leur sac de
couchage à l'arrière du renault scénic
et elles s'endorment de mon point de vue
je viens de vivre l'une des plus grandes
trahisons de toute ma vie c'était ton
idée aux tripes et là je sais pas trop
pourquoi mais dans un élan de désespoir
et de rage on sort de la voiture et on
se met à chercher un spot où mettre la
tente sur le parking du camping on n'est
pas dans le déni je veux pas vous
entendre dire ça on y croit c'est tout
on est positif
on se rend donc à l'évidence on sait que
c'est mort qu'on pourra pas dormir là et
on reprend la route dans l'espoir de
trouver un carré d'herbe d'accord jamais
de ma vie je pensais chercher un carré
d'herbe et un psychiatre et des rondes
quoi jusqu'ici j'avais su à l'époque ce
qui arrive on cherche on est désespérés
théo il a un petit air de folie un
moment il dit les gars je comprends pas
sur google maps ya de l'herbe partout
pourquoi on n'en trouve pas il parle des
montagnes qui nous entourent c'est bon
c'est inexploitable je prend donc la
décision de me garer sur un parquet
celui de la plage et là j'essaie nous
rendre à l'évidence ce soir là on a
appelé tous les hôtels dans un rayon de
150 km on était prêt à rouler deux
heures juste pour dormir dans une
chambre d'hôtel on en pouvait pas
honnêtement l'échec fait mal j'en veux
vue entre croûte si on se retrouve à
devoir louer une chambre d'hôtel c'est
nul tous étaient complets il n'y avait
pas une chambre d'hôtel de libre on se
regarde sans dire un mot mais on sait
tous les trois ce qui va se passer
[Musique]
c'était la pire nuit de toute ma vie
mieux vaut pas dormir que dormir comme
ça vraiment c'est à dire dans une
voiture et un à trois la chaleur elle
monte de fou la cause de ces [ __ ] de
ce raid horreur je voulais pas laisser
les fenêtres de la voiture ouverte
j'avais peur qu'il m'arrive une
dinguerie pendant la nuit du coup il y
avait absolument aucune aération dont
vous respirez tous l'expiration des
autres c'est dégueulasse mais les
fenêtres y avait de la buée partout
dessus de la buée de sueur d'hommes mais
quand même j'arrive à dormir
ces courtes et à mon réveil surprise pas
ouf il ya vingt voitures garées autour
de nous le parking de la plage n'est
plus du tout vite les gens viennent à la
plage désormais viennent s'amuser et là
je vous cache pas je sais pas trop
pourquoi mais j'ai une paranoïa georges
est trop peur coup de stress je me dis
[ __ ] mais la grâce des gens qui sont
passés dans la voiture et qui m'ont vu
dormir comme ça
et j'avais trop peur que des gens mais
filmé et mis sur les réseaux dans cette
position alors que au pire bob c'est pas
grave je prends mon tel je commence à
regarder mais mention et personne n'a
fumé quoi les gens banyuls-sur-mer ils
vont à la plage quoi ils en ont rien à
[ __ ] de 3 blaireaux qui dorment dans
leurs caisses sonné ko on se pose sur la
plage on dort 3 4 heures et puis on
reprend la route direction l'espagne ont
traversé plein de petits villages hyper
mignon dans les pyrénées et puis on
emprunte un chemin et là on tombe sur un
spot idyllique un spot incroyable en
contrebas ya un grand lac et autour du
lac il ya des familles qui s'amusent il
fait beau malades ya du soleil médias
petite fraîcheur parfaite autour du lac
qui rafraîchit les gens vrais chevaux
jour on tombe là dessus sans s'y
attendre et ont des genres stupéfait
quoi c'est trop beau on s'approche du
lac en s'approchant on entend il a connu
la cinquième aventure c'est un bruit de
tyroliennes parce qu'au dessus du lac se
trouve un tir haut par frick leur haine
et jojo veulent pas y aller elle vont se
poser en bas près du lac évidemment théo
mon frère et moi on veut tyro s'amuser
une tyrolienne deux tyroliennes 3
tyrolienne
on se régale à la fin il ya même un truc
où tu dois avancer au dessus du vide sur
un câble mentale alors extrêmement
vulnérables a jugé pas ok tu t'accroches
à un câble et tu sautes fins et c'est
vraiment des trucs de sensations et moi
j'ai peur du vide de fou alors pourquoi
je vous parle du tir au parc parce
qu'aux tirs au parc il ya des tirs aux
employés et franchement les tirs aux
employés ils sont graves sympa tellement
sympa qui nous propose après leur
journée de travail de nous rejoindre
près du lac et qu'on fasse une petite
soirée ensemble et c'est cette soie dont
je veux vous voir les membres ont
rejoint donc lorraine et jojo au bord du
lac on se pose on fait la sieste pendant
plusieurs heures la nuit commence à
tomber il est 20 heures et la soirée
commence nouvel objectif trouver du bois
pour faire du feu mais eux ils rigolent
pas du tout ils sortent une tronçonneuse
d'un poste mon frérot est montée haut
d'une montagne et coupe un arbre ils le
prennent à 5 et je sais pas trop comment
mais il faut un peu avec oi je suis
choqué et on commence à tous faire
connaissance raconte un peu nos vies
genre nos passions notre métier notre
histoire c'est genre trop bien mais plus
le temps passe plus les gens ont bu plus
donc ils sont bourrés et plus le ton ils
changent un peu genre chaque minute qui
passe je suis un peu moins à l'aise que
la minute d'avant par exemple je suis
dans une discussion avec deux personnes
et d'un coup m10 comme ça d'un coup sans
contexte qu'elle adore écrasé les
crapauds qui a autour du lac bon je suis
pas choqué chacun ses délires mais je me
dis tu es pas pour t'amuser lancé
warzone fin je sais pas après chacun son
délire quoi qu'il en soit rien
d'alarmant réellement et puis quelqu'un
me raconte autre chose sorti de nulle
part un mec me regarde et me dis [ __ ]
mon père il s'est pris une balle dans le
ventre ya pas longtemps moi ça me met
mal je suis triste pour lui pour son
père je dis [ __ ] comment ça se fait
c'est quoi il se balade en forêt et il
s'est pris une balle d'un chasseur qui
chassait mon moi enfin c'est quoi ces
séquelles genre d'accidents hélas il dit
les gars je suis je sais pas comment
réagir avec cette info sur ça que je
vous la donne il est un peu affecté par
ça mais là d'une manière très posé il
dit non non c'est juste qu'il s'est
fâché que ma belle-mère et puis elle a
il lui a tiré dans le ventre quoi
pardon mais moi je m'énerve je fronce
les sourcils frérot c'est tout je prends
mes bowles lui dis mes mecs c'est grave
tu te rends pas compte près du tout j'ai
juste répondu d'accord fin la soirée
continue hélas pendant qu'on parle je
réalise que genre j'ai mal à l'oreille
je réalise que j'ai un acouphène aussi à
l'oreille je laisse les yeux j'ai mal et
je vois qu'ils se montrent dignes à une
trace celui d'un pétard qui vient
d'exploser mais qu'est ce qu'un pétard
faisait sur ma jambe allumé bah c'est
très simple dans leur groupe un pyromane
et il s'amuse très régulièrement allumé
des pétards et amener envoyé dessus
heureusement je suis pas un crapaud il
mourrait écrasé suis là je réalise ça
donc réaction normale je me lève je
regarde dans les yeux du 10 mai que tu
fais quoi là c'est un manque de respect
pas du tout je reste assis une lance
très souvent des pétards dessus ça
explose j'ai mal à l'oreille je fais je
suis pas à l'aise du tout je parle aux
gens etc il ya un mec à qui j'ai pas
parlé de la soirée qui vient boire je
lui dis alors toi aussi frérot tu bosses
au tir au parc et ils me regardent comme
sahin pokerface et me dit je suis pas
ton frérot
je suis pas ton frérot il a dit
je peux me transformer en tronc d'arbre
je veux mais là celle-là je suis choqué
encore bref après tout ce que je viens
de vivre je suis crime je suis mal à
l'aise jusqu'à la fin de la soirée il
est 4h du mat il nous propose de finir
la soirée à la salle polyvalente du
village ce à quoi on répond non ils ne
prennent pas mal heureusement sont
dorées puce prend une balle dans le
ventre ils s'en vont il est maintenant
temps pour nous pour la première fois
depuis début du road trip de monter la
tente et oui on trouve un spot dans la
forêt près du lac ont la déplie ce
moment pour moi je vais comme une
délivrance comme un accomplissement
depuis deux mois qu'on parlait de faire
cette semaine route ça y est c'est le
moment de la première née dans la tente
je m'installe dans mon sac de couchage
me mets sur deux je ferme les yeux et
latéraux et montréal assiste à la
naissance de sarko squeeze
là bas je suis mort là il ya mes proches
qui vont passer un peu en bad en
espérant que je me réveille pierre
malentendu sur le bilan médical
finalement l'objectif a été atteint on a
fait une nuit dans une tente au milieu
de la forêt à un spot qu'on a trouvé une
heure avant et ça c'était vraiment cool
je leur ferai jamais jamais les amis
j'ai fini de vous raconter les deux
premiers jours de mon retrait je vous
raconte pas la suite parce qu'elle est
beaucoup plus classique il ya beaucoup
moins de rencontre bizarre on s'est
habitué à dormir mal voilà que ce soit
dans une tente ou ailleurs on dormait
mal mais c'était l'avion s'est habitué
bref ce truc là je l' ai vécu vraiment
de manière intense et je voulais vous
raconter j'espère que ça vous a plu
prenez soin de vous les cerises hausse
on se retrouve bientôt dans d'autres
vidéos d'ailleurs décidé sans y aura
plusieurs grosses vidéos qui sortiront
plusieurs concept est nouveau et parfois
la suite de trucs que vous avez beaucoup
aimé as tu voyais tout ça à prenez soin
de vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]